let me pull out my soapbox for a minute
here please stop calling yourself not
for profit
right that is a tax delineation right
and no one wants to be defined by what
you're not uh
first that's number one number two of
course you're profitable you just don't
define profit in terms of dollars and
cents
if you're if you set up a an
organization to rescue kittens out of
trees you better be profitable because
it means you're rescuing more chicken
chick uh kittens out of trees than not
so
just redefine how you define profit stop
calling yourselves uh
not for profit and start calling
yourselves four impact organizations
that's the first way to get your back on
track because what it does
it what it does is it puts your why
front and center and not money
money is just an object it's just it's
fuel money is fuel you need fuel to make
the car go
but that's not why the car exists um
you're a four impact organization the
question
is is what impact are you trying to make
in the world and that's how you can help
keep your why front and center which is
you're constantly constantly constantly
reminding yourself of it
it's written on the walls i think one of
the big mistakes that a lot of
four impact organizations make is they
actually don't know how to define their
cause
it's we want to change the world well i
don't know what that looks like
you know great vision is something that
you can imagine in your mind's eye and
the great leaders in our world whether
they're
business leaders political leaders or
civil uh uh
civil leaders are able to articulate
vision in terms that we can imagine
ourselves in that world i have a dream
that one day little black children will
hold hands on the playground with little
white children like you can see that in
your mind's eye
paint a picture for us and then set
yourself on course
towards that i think the other thing is
um four impact organizations need to
stop competing against each other it
drives me nuts
um you know two two organizations that
are
trying to help you know find the cure
for cancer competing against each other
you've got to be nuts
one has strength the other one has
weaknesses this one has strength that
the other one has weaknesses why not
combine forces
um you're more likely to find the cure
for cancer if you actually work together
as opposed to
in competition with each other but the
whole idea is keep the y front and
center in crystal clear terms that we
can imagine
and call yourself a four impact
organization it'll go a long way